Do you get nostalgic ... Are you nostalgic when we talk about ABBA?
No, I can't actually say that I am.
It wasn't like I was ...
But everyone else is!
It's not like I wish that I was still standing there -
- like Mick Jagger is.
It was good while it lasted.
So I look back on it with joy and gratitude.
But would you, in theory, be able to?
No, I don't think so.
If you for example ask Benny, he would say: «NO, that won't work»!
When you get questions about ABBA, do you have to ask the other members, or ...
It's enough that one of us says «no».
Questions like «may we use 'Dancing Queen' in this movie» -
Then we say «no».
There's a lot of questions like that.
And then there's also quite a lot of interesting requests, someone who wants to create a game -
- whatever it may be called ... What was the name of the one recently?
«You can dance»?
«Singstar», I think it was called.
Some kind of karaoke setup with our old videos.
And that kind of thing can be quite cool. So then we said «yes»!
And if someone says «yes», we have to check with all four.
And ask if everyone thinks it's okay.
I wonder ...
When you look at Björn and Benny, they've both been here -
- and now you ... All three of you have got in common that you ...
You want to be ordinary.
In some way.
We ARE ordinary.
Is Frida as ordinary as the rest of you?
Yes. I think so.
So the four of you are the same level of ordinary?
Yes, one could say that. We're the same level of boring!
If we go back in time -
- was one of you the boss?
I would say that all of us were the boss.
We were very strong people, all of us.
And were will strong.
And I think that's the reason it worked out so well.
Who would buckle first?
It certainly wasn't me!
We really enjoyed ourselves because we all -
- were gifted and we all had something to contribute with.
And I had quite a lot of -
- ideas about choruses and little -
- inserts here and there so we could make the songs a little more -
- alive, in a way. Like a little gimmick in every song.
So that was probably my contribution.
And people have asked why I didn't write more material for ABBA but -
- I also had periods where I felt that «God, it's so nice to be home».
We were traveling a lot, and I had two small children at home -
- and when I came home I just felt that -
I wanted to take care of that. I went from ...
... a luxury suite to -
- doing the dishes -
- and I thought it was wonderful!
You were born after ABBA?
Yes.
It was my fault!
What does ABBA mean to you?
Ha-ha, your fault!
To me, ABBA is naturally something -
- very nice. And -
- the part about them never reuniting ...
Personally, I think that's sad, even if I understand why.
It would have been cool.
And it's somewhere ....
It's hard to answer, I don't really have anything to compare it to.
You've been asked about this a thousand times, and -
- it's very clear that you don't want to.
But there's one thing I've been wondering about:
Have you had the talk?
If we've had ..?
Have you had the talk about reuniting?
No.
Have you had the one meeting where you've sat down and agreed ..?
We received an offer ten years ago.
Which I don't believe at all.
That we would receive an enormous amount of money -
- to play 100 concerts in a year.
Completely sponsored or what it was.
And the amount was so big that we called each other and asked «what do you think?»
And everyone said «nooo».
So it's quite easy, actually.
So it's not like there's one poor person who really wants to do it?
No, it's not like that. No one wants to.
You agree?
Yes.
Then it sounds like it won't happen.
As of yet.
«As of yet»! That's good to hear!
We'll see.
Can't you push a little?
Sure, I'll do that.
Would you be able to ... Do you have another «Mamma Mia» in you?
Would you be able to write «Dancing Queen» today?
I think that pop music is best written by -
- young people -
- when they're at the height of their creativity.
Every person has a period like that, I think.
And that might just last for only ten years.
And later you might enter some other form of creativity.
But just that peak ...
We had that in the 70's -
- together with ABBA.
You have got ...
... fans all over the world.
They got in contact when they heard you were coming here.
Does it happen that you connect with someone over time, or -
- is it just one reply, and then ...
Well, yes ...
There are a few people who I've gotten to know over time -
- and who I keep in touch with.
There is one special fan. He -
- got in contact four years ago.
And this is a story that really touches me.
He came from humble circumstances.
He was around 60 when he began writing me.
He trained to be a butcher when he was 16 years old.
And when the foot-and-mouth disease broke out in England in 2002 -
- he was summoned by the authorities -
- to help butcher all these livestock that had been infected.
And he went through a horrible period -
- partly because he was forced to butcher all these animals -
- in a special way, which I'll avoid telling the details about -
- but in addition -
- he took part in the families sorrow over losing their income.
And this resulted in him getting a severe depression.
Where he eventually decided that he would take his own life.
And ...
He was on his way to do it.
He brought his favorite ABBA tape with him.
Which he listened to. And he brought his rifle.
And he went out to finish it.
Just when he's ready -
- ABBA sings «The Way Old Friends Do».
And he stops and listens to these lyrics.
And he thinks: «This is exactly what life is like».
You have to ...
Be together with friends and -
- help each other and be there.
Like old friends do to each other.
And he had left his wife without saying anything to her, naturally.
And he had children and grandchildren, he had a big family.
So he changed.
Because of this song.
And he went back to his wife and told her everything.
And then I received this letter where he told the whole story to me.
And we continued to communicate.
And I was, of course, very taken.
So I wrote him a quite long and friendly letter.
And after that we stayed in touch.
And he wrote me a letter once a month -
- where he told me about his life, his family,  his friends -
- about his hobbies, everything he did.
He was a wonderful writer.
He wrote really, really well.
Then what happened eventually was that he got lung cancer -
- and he passed away in February this year.
And that was sad.